sit down don't know it's about about
Egyptology you
I'm ed and I'm a gemologist
why are they always these are often
being drawn those kinds of things in
like temples or in to images have a
magical power which is why you don't
represent people who are missing bits so
that could translate into the next world
do you want to show kind of all the
parts of a person show their whole torso
but then you show the side of their face
why did they always walk like that Egypt
has a lot of very narrow corridors and
so yeah they're always heard of having
to do this to kind of get through why
did they mostly in order to scare
children in contemporary wealth the
Egyptians saw people as being composed
of several kind of aspects a person
could be viewed from different ways but
only ever from only ever from the this
way one of which was the body so they
mummify you ideally break this bone in
the nose stuff some linen up there
scrambling around with a hook pull it
out to get the brain accident to care
about the brain there's osiris a god on
earth he's ruling the earth at the
moment with his wife Isis who's also his
sister but we don't judge his brother
Seth is really jealous of him so he's
like argh I will kill you and he did cut
him up and scattered him everywhere Isis
was very upset by this gathered all the
bits and brought them together and bound
him creating the first mummy and brought
him back to life but this wasn't before
she kinda had sex with him while he was
a buddy and then kind of conceived their
son Horus through that sets towards the
throne he wants to kill Horace so they
hide Horus away until he's old enough
and then he comes back to fight Seth
they also turned into hippopotamus for a
bit and had a fight they also had sex
with each other I could also mention
that hey guys make love not war and they
were like oh okay some weird stuff
happens involving semen Horace's trick
Seth into eating some of his own semen
on a lettuce I challenge you to rap
about pyramids yeah I'm just so stations
they're on mummies and mummification and
ancient aliens okay cool pyramids
mummification and
aliens y'all building pyramids they were
keen they got it organized I say though
that's a pyramid scheme PS like a
postscript yo they the mostest
when you got the pyramids you know they
got those hits the three at Giza none
can be easier they go so high up the
charts like Weezer song yeah we know
everyone likes them but I see the
pyramids I remember again they got full
sides yeah and all the faces that would
be five sides in all of the places don't
forget the vases
and then the indices I think that means
it from my mathematics date but pyramids
y'all with like a regal tomb put the
mummified body under watch it consume
yeah it's like a kind of thing between
the men and gods
I see mummification and they say is so
odd why do you not leave the organs
inside of the body you fumble around the
brain pull it out it looks study you
slice them open and put them in the tomb
stuff the body with the sodium and
there's some perfume let them dry out yo
what's that about I open the canopic jar
and the whiff comes out I'm like oh so
pong he offends and wrongs me I give
this away you'd go for a song not free
because Egyptian artifacts have value
that's why people go and steal from the
Valley of the Kings you know yeah like
the y'all bros though Cleopatra was a
queen and she was on shelves last then
let me say again back there with ancient
aliens coming down from the sky like an
American dollar bill coming down year
like a pyramid Hill going down with the
spaceships UFO over to the New Kingdom
they go to the Nile white and blue were
they the Kozol red I don't know they get
that crown give it up to the leader give
it up to the pharaoh yeah you know they
succeed I believe we've got the
monuments and artefacts the seem to look
like an alien but not painting green
they got big-ass and space helmets there
maybe it might confuse you while you sit
in your chair okay
then we finished today ancient aliens
anonymous because they a a what a lovely
generic I enjoy nicely glowy